[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
sodium chloride is formed when the
unstable metal sodium reacts with
chlorine gas it's the only family of
rocks that are regularly eaten by humans
that's right we're talking about salt
the average adult's body contains about
250 grams of sodium that's the
equivalent about three or four shakers
of salt while too much salt is not good
it remains essential for the health of
our bodies salt facilitates the
transport of nutrients and oxygen
allowing our nerves and muscles to work
salts ability to preserve food is one of
the major factors in the development of
civilization it also made it possible to
transport food over long distances
historians tell us at the peak of the
salt trade caravans with as many as 40
thousand camels traversed across the
Sahara bringing salt to markets
yes entire empires were built on the
salt trade and it was often used as
currency roman legionnaires were
sometimes paid with salt which is where
we get the word salary and when a
soldier wasn't pulling his weight they
said he was not worth his salt perhaps
this is why Jesus said Christians are
the salt of the earth to stay with his
friends were gonna learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to you
Bible questions
welcome listening friends if you've got
a Bible question that's what this
program is all about we are live and if
you want to call in with your question
we've got lines open right now here is
the phone number it's eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven an
acronym for that is 800 God says that's
how you can remember the number 800 God
says that's 800 for six three seven two
nine seven you give us a call right now
a really good chance we're gonna get to
your question on tonight's broadcast
we're gonna be here for the next 55
minutes or so we're also streaming the
program now on Facebook if you want to
watch and see what's happening here in
our humble studio and that then if
that's what the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page and at the amazing facts Facebook
page and I am Doug Batchelor I mean Jean
Ross good evening friends and as we
always do let's start our program with
prayer dear father we thank you that
we're able to open up your word and
study together the most important book
of all that is the Bible and father we
pray for the spirit - got our minds and
people those who are listening Lord all
across the country and around the world
and in a special way we just want to
pray for the social situation that we
find ourselves in here in America and
just pray that peace would reign and you
would be able to allow these
circumstances to ultimately draw people
closer to you and a realization of where
we living for we ask this in Jesus name
Amen
amen well pastor Doug were open the
program with an amazing fact about salt
and how the Bible says that Christians
ought to be the salt of the earth and if
anyone's been watching the news I think
you aware that if ever there was a need
for christ-like love and patience it's
now especially with the social
conditions that's happening in the world
yeah absolutely you know Jesus sets a
marvelous example for overcoming evil
with good you do not overcome evil with
evil I think that you know the Bible
says an
for an i but that's talking about how
governments deal with with things
civilly in our relationships with each
other sometimes you know we we we love
we fight with love and Jesus and Gandhi
and others you know they were great
examples in peaceful protest and making
statements like that and they were able
to affect great change I think everybody
in the in the country who you know is
aware what happened when we we saw that
tragic death it is recoiled on the news
and but now we're you know we're seeing
an equal tragedy in you know people's
anger flaring and you know we would just
appeal for this Christian should be
praying right now they should be set in
an example praying for God's Spirit to
to give wisdom to how to resolve some of
these terrible a challenges we have in
our society in a christ-like way
absolutely pastor Doug and I think if
ever there was a time for Christians to
you know stand together demonstrating
the love of Christ but now would be the
time that's so important now we do have
a free offer that talks about the
importance of a Christian standing for
principles that are true and right even
if it means standing alone in the crowd
think of the example of Shadrach Meshach
and Abednego who's standing on the plain
of Dura everybody else bow down to the
golden image but they refuse to
compromise they refuse to break God's
commandments so this book talks about
the importance of Christians being able
to stand for truth stand for their
commitment to Christ even in a society
and in a world that has set aside the
principles of God set aside the truths
of his word and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who would call and ask
this is our free offer this evening if
you'd like to receive that but the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and as
for our free offer a book is entitled
alone in the crowd and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven our phone line here to the studio
if you have a Bible related question is
800 four six three seven two nine seven
that's eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven and we're gonna go straight to the
phone lines our first caller this
evening we got that KB listening in
Maryland Katie welcome to the program
doing good thank you for calling oh
thank you for taking my question
no and you go ahead once you share that
all right so I've been reading and I've
been sharing and there's one thing
that's kind of difficult to share cuz
today explanation it's revelation 12:3
and it describes a dragon with seven
heads and ten horns and then when you're
reading in revelation 13:1 it talks
about a beast with seven heads and ten
toes you might think that it's a
description of the same thing until you
get to chapter 13 verse 4 where it says
the dragon gives power to the beast so
can you please explain why the
descriptions of the dragon and the Beast
are similar nearly identical and what
each represents yeah well in both
Revelation 12 you have this beast seven
heads ten horns revelation 13 be seven
heads ten horns and if you go to
Revelation 17 you're gonna see it again
Katie where the woman is sitting on a
beast with seven heads and ten horns in
all three cases it is the devil working
through the power of Rome and it was the
devil working through Herod where he
kills the babies in Bethlehem in
Revelation 12 it's the devil working
through a corruption of Rome in
Revelation chapter 13 it's it's the you
know when Rome fell it turned into the
divisions of the Western Roman Empire
which were those ten kingdoms and you
see that again in Revelation 17 so it's
very consistent and you read in
revelation 17 verse 13 it says that
woman you saw as the great city that
reigns over the kings of the earth
I mean revelation 17 last verse I don't
think it's verse 13 revelation 17 it
says the woman you saw is the great city
that reigns over the kings of the earth
that was Rome that was raining then that
had put Paul in prison on the Isle of
Patmos so are you
struggling because you're wondering in
Revelation 12 is that beast the kingdom
of Rome in Revelation 13 it's something
else no I'm trying to explain to others
you know the dragon and they worshipped
the Dragon which gave power unto the
Beast and the the Beast and the dragon
is two different seems like it's two
different things and I'm thinking that
it's you know the false religion and the
devil the devil giving power to the
false religion well I'm explaining that
correctly you know there's some overlap
and now John's gonna jump in here but
you you can see in Revelation 12 it says
that dragon is the old serpent the devil
and Satan well because that's the power
behind all of these beasts and he was
working through the Roman Empire at the
time Jesus was born to both persecute
Christ as a baby and then execute him as
a man yeah absolutely you know beast in
Bible prophecy according to Daniel
represents a political power according
to chapter 12 of Revelation the dragon
is identified as the devil but the
dragon has similar characteristics to
this beast power the first beast of
Revelation 13 so that would tell us that
this political power is being influenced
or motivated by the dragon which is the
satanic power so you have a kingdom that
is being used by the devil to persecute
God's people and of course we've seen
that all the way back in the Old
Testament when you have Babylon you'll
first the Assyrians that conquered the
ten tribes of northern Israel
he had Babylon conquering Jerusalem and
the Jews you had during the time of Rome
and they were persecuting Christ
followers and then during the New
Testament era you had pagan Rome
persecuting and eventually papal Rome
that also persecuted but the power
behind all of that is the dragon or
Satan persecuting the followers of
Christ so there is a connection and
that's why I think there's similarities
between the dragon and the beasts that
we find in chapter 13 and 17 you know we
have a book Katie we'd like to send you
that I think I was looking around in our
resources we have that great book by Joe
Cruz called the beast the dragon and the
woman because I think touches on all
three of those beasts and makes it
really clear just call Katie will send
you a
we copy the number to call is 883 five
six seven four seven and again the book
is entitled the dragon the beast and
Babylon beasts the dragon the woman we
did a documentary yeah and that's a good
one too that is and I think that's
available and amazing facts at the
website or I think it's even available
on YouTube
yeah right the bride the beast in
Babylon a bride-to-be says the tongue
twister but you'll be able to see it
there and we'll be happy to send out the
book with a similar name the beast the
woman beast the dragon and the woman
they okay well yeah they serve so many
beasts and women in Revelation thanks
for your call Katie we've got Mike
listening in st. Louis Missouri Mike
welcome to the program doing good well
here's my question it concerns Leviticus
chapter 23 verse 17 and I wrote it down
and here it is do the two loaves of
bread baked with leaven or yeast and I
put this in parenthesis for myself that
yeast symbolize the sin and corruption
close parenthesis and the Pentecost
ceremony here's my question
represent that Israelites in
non-israelites both need salvation
that's what I'm saying the ceremony's
about yeah just to look at that you
referring to Leviticus 23 correct yeah
our seventeen yeah it's before you
getting that pastor like just to add to
that this is part of the ceremonial
feasts that God had instructed Israel
all of which had a type and I pointing
to Christ in one form or another there
were times when they needed to bring
unleavened bread as an offering but on
the feast of weeks that Leviticus 23 is
talking about what's kind of interesting
that this is to be bread baked with
leaven
so of course 11 also represents sin but
it was also in this sense to represent I
think as is mentioned that Christ's
sacrifice is for all all have sinned and
come short of the glory of God we ought
to give ourselves as an offering to
Christ
is the spotless one he is the unleavened
bread so to speak he is without sin but
we are to bring ourselves to Christ and
humble our hearts so not only does the
unleavened bread represent Christ but I
think the leavened bread that we find
here could represent individuals could
represent us needing to surrender
ourselves and give ourselves to Christ
yeah you know so it's there's some
things that are a little deep you know
the Bible tells us that a lion sometimes
is the devil the devil goes around like
a roaring lion because there are
attributes of the devil that are lion
like but then you get to Revelation it
says the line of the tribe of Judah is
Jesus king of the beasts so you get the
same creature and he's described in two
different ways lemon is one of those
things that because it was you know it
would rise the bread and almost seem
mysterious sometimes eleven was bad but
then you look in Luke 13 21 the kingdom
of heaven is like leaven that a woman
took and hid in three measures of meal
this is Jesus speaking till all was 11
in other words it was to permeate and
make things grow and here in Jesus is
using leaven in a good sense there's an
offering yeah so you know you can see it
being used both ways and I think in
Leviticus it's talking about the
positive aspect of leaven there hey
thank you very much hope that helps a
little Mike appreciate your question
makes folder that we have is Reuben I
believe calling from Oxnard California
Reuben welcome to the program thank you
and I enjoy your your program very much
and my question is since um we see all
all the chaos is going to the work in
this world now and when I read Matthew
24 you know the Lord Jesus Christ said
Luke you know once you see this sign so
my question is is this time to live the
CD and run for the hills
well I would not
by the way Reuben is quoting from
Matthew 24 and it says when you
therefore see the abomination of
desolation spoken of by Daniel the
prophet standing in the Holy Place
whoever reads let him understand that
then let those that be in Judea flee
into the mountains so Christ is giving a
very specific guideline for what you
look for and this was also found in Luke
chapter 21 the interesting thing is in
Luke 21 he says when you see Jerusalem
encompassed with armies let those that
be in Judea flee into the mountains in
the last days when Christians see that
we're being hedged in with religious
laws that's going to be a sign that the
beast power is going to begin to compel
regarding how we're supposed to worship
I think Christians better off if they
don't live in the middle of a city where
you know the chaos is going to be a lot
more intense and you know as time goes
by we're probably going to be better off
being out in the country especially if
you have children as far as whether you
should drop everything and run for the
hills see Christ when he said this at
one point he says if you're on your roof
do not even come into your house to get
your clothes he says if you're in the
field don't go back to your house to get
anything so Christ is talking about a
time of great crisis when you are to run
from the cities now I don't want to be
the Holy Spirit but I don't think that
that's what's happening just now you
know we've had riots before and we've
had economic crashes before so if the
Holy Spirit's telling your family it's
time to plan to relocate that may be
true I don't think this is the time
where Jesus said jump off your roof and
run for the hills
so you still there Ruben yeah yep you're
here so I hope that made sense you know
I have a book and we just printed this
book it's something I can't give away
but it doesn't cost much
it's called heading for the hills a
beginner's guide to country living you
know I believe as much as anybody in
country living and just about a week ago
I was up in the hills ten miles from the
nearest person so yeah I
you speak it fluently but I think
Christians also have to caution against
doing anything impulsively unless
they're really being guided by the
spirit when it comes to making a big
career change and relocating their
families all right well thanks for your
cole Ruben next caller listening from
Texas we got me Selena me Celina welcome
to the program hello how are you pastors
great thank you for calling yes my
question is is the following in Matthew
28:19 20 when Jesus commanded to be
baptized in the name of the Father and
of the Son and of the Holy Ghost and
then in acts 2:38 Peter stands up and
tells the people to repent and to be
baptized in the name of Jesus my
question is why in all the baptisms that
were recorded in the New Testament it's
done in the name of Jesus and not in
that name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Ghost and actually and
pastor ross may have to look up the
reference for me even in the book of
Acts it's worded differently I think one
time it says in the name of the Lord
Jesus and another time it says in the
name of the Lord as far as being
baptized so because there's a little
variation in the wording we need to
assume the important thing about baptism
was not the utterance as though you had
to say things a certain way or you were
unqualified baptism is very much like a
wedding for you know in a wedding you're
making a covenant you're making a public
covenant legally what makes a covenant
binding is that the people involved and
any witnesses understand who the parties
are making the covenant with so when we
perform marriages as pastors sometimes
the couple will say you know in our
wedding vows we want you to say bill do
you take Jane they want it very very
simple the witnesses all know these two
parties are getting married and they're
making a covenant sometimes they'll say
instead of saying bill we want you to
say
William James Smith will you take Jane
Bettina Pierson and it's a little more
formal
either way the Covenant is just as
binding and so when Jesus had baptized
in the name of the Father Son and Holy
Spirit baptized in the name of Jesus
Christ baptized in the name of the Lord
did you find the other reference yeah we
got acts 15 26 and acts in 19 verse 5
talks about the Lord Jesus Christ and
then the Lord Jesus yeah so your wording
is a little different in each one miss
alline so what we do in our church is we
we try to cover all the bases we baptize
people in the name of the Father His Son
Jesus Christ and the Holy Spirit and you
know if you're following the words of
Jesus you're safe so and and those
covenants are valid okay so let's say
that somebody is baptized in the name of
Jesus what they have to be baptized
again and name of the Father Son and the
Holy Ghost that cover cover the bases
you know well I think it would cover the
bases now just keep in mind when the
disciples went out the first baptisms
you're reading about there in acts these
were Jews who were just hearing about
Jesus for the first time and they
already knew about God the Father and
they knew about the Holy Spirit and so
Peters emphasizing getting baptized in
the name of Jesus not just the baptism
John the Baptist offered and you know it
never tells us I think John the Baptist
off baptized in the name of Jehovah the
Lord so Peter was emphasizing Jesus name
in the book of Acts because most of the
Jews didn't understand that part you
know we do have a study guide talking
about baptism and it's called purity and
power and it does address these verses
Matthew 28 and others and of course
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
for free or their life today just call
our resource number that's eight hundred
eight thirty five six seven four seven
and ask for the study guide it's called
purity and power and we have a book
called the name of the Lord where I
specifically talk about what name should
you be baptized in
and I will send that to you free as well
this is called the name of the Lord all
right one more time that resource number
just to make sure yet it is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven we have two books we will be able
to send you the ones actually one of our
study guides it's called purity and
power and the other one is the name of
the Lord and so call for that and we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
us now thanks for your call our next
caller is Debbie listening in New York
may be welcome to the program
occurrences are we seeing major cities
in response to the murder of George
Floyd most recently in Minneapolis also
Brianna Terra in Louisville Kentucky and
I'm not Audrey in Georgia my question is
in light of everything that's going on
what should the response of the church
be I feel as if there's a lot of racial
tension and a lot of people feel as if
the truth has really lost the moral high
ground because it seems as if tich are
okay to sort of turn a blind eye to
summon justices as long as some of their
pets concerns are addressed ie same-sex
marriage and abortion so long as the
politicians that the support align in
their view of those there was two
particular issues then issues of race
they tend to be quite silent on and
quite frankly throughout this whole
process I'm not really hearing that you
speak on issues on this issue and I'm
just wondering what should the response
of church leadership be in this present
situation okay thank you very much
Debbie you know well first of all it's
as heart-wrenching what we see happening
right now I think everybody knows that
there is profiling you know most
thinking people see statistically there
profiling that's happening and whenever
there's injustice Christians should
defend truth and the downtrodden you
know Jesus was always a great defender
of the poor and those were being
maligned and whether it was Samaritans
in his day or it was the woman at the
well you know Jesus was always speaking
up for those that were being mistreated
and I think Christians should continue
to follow the example of Christ
yeah just acting a little pastor day you
know Christ is I example in all things
and without a doubt Jesus did talk about
the importance of helping those in need
and the poor but Jesus also emphasized
how that the true help that can be given
is through the gospel through the
preaching of the word individuals taking
the love of Christ and revealing that to
others so I think as a church first and
foremost we need to make sure that in
our churches amongst how believers that
we recognized that we're all sons and
daughters of God there is no
preferential treatment for one above
another in God's eyes were all his
children and I think the church needs to
be example a example number one of a
unity in the midst of backgrounds and
different races that we United because
we are committed to Christ into the
gospel I think at appropriate times the
other church can speak out but I don't
think the church needs to allow itself
to perhaps be distracted I'm not saying
this is the case but I think as a church
we need to recognize that we don't want
to distract and there's a lot of good
causes that a church could probably get
involved in but we don't to be we don't
want to be distracted from the Great
Commission or the great mission that
Christ is given in the preaching of the
gospel so there are times I think a
church can can help in a very practical
sense but I think we also need to
recognize our first priority is the
preaching of the gospel and the
demonstrating of the love of Christ the
root of all anger and injustice is the
lack of the Spirit of God in people's
lives and if we would spend more time
addressing
what is the root that causes injustice
and that's the preaching of the gospel
that helps us remember that God is made
of one blood all nations that we are all
brothers and sisters through Christ and
we're brothers and sisters through Adam
and Noah and so yeah if people could
just remember that and and the church
needs to model that but absolutely
Debbie and I hope that helps a little
bit let me see words we got 48 seconds
so other questions are gonna have to
happen on the other side of the break
and you know one of the important things
that and some people might think that
this is a sort of dismissive response
but I think we underestimate the power
of prayer
you know God says if my people will
humble themselves and pray and seek my
face and turn from their wicked ways
then I will hear from heaven I will
forgive their sin and heal their land
meaning their country and if his people
will humble themselves and pray and the
thing right now God's people in the
churches need to be praying and asking
for a transformation that his spirit
would go through people's hearts
don't go away friends we're coming back
we're gonna be taking more Bible
questions in just a moment
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 qui going to noise
Jonathan in Delaware Jonathan welcome to
the program hey guys how's it going good
thank you for calling so I'll be brief
question something that I come upon with
a buddy of mine in light of today's
circumstances you know some people have
mentioned to me that in these final days
we are that our church may symbolize the
Church of Laodicea mhm and so I was just
curious as to what does it mean when
Jesus says you know if you were hot or
cold but since you're lukewarm I spit
you out of my mouth I kind of want to
understand what that means in light of
the context but in light of what a
Christian you know I guess should do or
what that tells us is a Christian today
does that make sense yes well the answer
to that is and by the way this is in
Revelation chapter 3 you can read verses
14 verse through verse 21 and it's a
message the last message to the Church
of Laodicea of the seven messages lay
osya was a city that it got its water
through a long aqueduct and by the time
it got to town it wasn't hot it wasn't
cold it was just out there in the open
air kind of lukewarm and in Bible times
if you boiled water it came from a hot
spring you were probably safe to drink
at her
was in cool running Creek it was
probably safe standing warm water could
make you sick and if a person took a
drink of standing warm water they go
home that's the stuff that makes you
sick and they'd spew it out for the
church to come to the place where we are
lukewarm it means we're we think we're
rich and increased with Goods we don't
know that we're poor wretched miserable
blind and naked Jesus is saying if you
were hot on fire out working for me full
of zeal I can work with that if we're
cold if we realize our sin and were
repentant and we're on our knees he can
work with that he can forgive us and
give us a spirit he's not saying I would
that you were saved or lost hot means
you're on fire serving God cold means
that you're in a state of repentance
seeking after God he can work with
people who are in either those
conditions but when you are lost and you
think you're saved that's a very
dangerous condition you know we do have
a book that deals with this it's called
twelve steps to revival I think that's
the point the church in the last days
needs genuine revival men the Bible says
you think you're rich increased with
Goods and you have need of nothing well
that's spiritually describing the
condition of the church we need genuine
revival and we'll be happy to send this
book to anyone of course we know God is
the one that brings revival it's through
the spirit but is there something we can
do to prepare our hearts for revival the
book is called twelve steps to revival
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls an ass it's an important
subject the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and just asked for that book
called twelve steps to revival and we'll
be happy to send it to you Thank You
Jonathan next quarter the behave is Toni
listening in Kentucky Toni welcome to
the program good evening guys thank you
for taking my call yes sir
and you're correct my question oh sorry
my question is kind of a problem but I'm
gonna try to make it as quick as I can
so I've noticed for the last few months
and especially with this Korona thing
that like we as a church and I'm you
know in general everywhere out there it
seems like we're powerless against this
thing
if we look at you know our our track
record and I guess to kind of go with
that I've noticed in my personal life if
I compare my personal life and if I
compare Christianity with the Bible I
noticed that we don't I don't have a lot
of power in my life and the Christianity
doesn't seem to have a lot of power
these days either and you know the Bible
in the Bible people were guided by God
you know God spoke with them literally
and they literally spoke back to God and
I guess what my question is how do we
get all that back the the speaking with
the God that the raising people from the
dead the healing the power everything we
don't seem to have right now how are we
gonna get that back alright thank you
good question how do we return to the
power the faith that was once delivered
to the Saints the power that we see
among the early church well what did
they do how did they get the power they
walked with Jesus for three and a half
years and he poured out the Holy Spirit
and the Bible says to ask of the Lord
rain in the time of the latter rain and
he will send bright showers jesus said
you will be my witnesses when the Holy
Spirit comes on you
we need the baptism of the Holy Spirit
on the church and that's going to come
from people walking with the Lord
seeking after God through his word
through prayer if you have a revival in
the Church of people seeking after God
he promises if we draw near to him he
will draw near to us and as we do that
he will then infuse us once again with
that primitive power that we read about
I believe all of the signs and wonders
and miracles that we see in the days of
the Apostles you will see repeated again
before the second coming in the church
the church needs to repent and to pray
for revival when the people of God
repented in the days of Elijah he sent
the rain and if we would humble
ourselves before God he will once again
send the rain you know past that I've
just been looking through our books that
we have and so many of them deal with
the subject because it's important
subject to revival and one of the books
that stands out I think he's an
excellent resource called the Holy
Spirit the need
and at the end of the day that's what we
are seeking we are seeking for more of
the Holy Spirit just like in the days of
the Apostles on the day of Pentecost
where the Holy Spirit came upon them and
we need to be asking for the Holy Spirit
asking about experience the book talks
about this it's called the Holy Spirit
the need written by pastor Doug if you'd
like to get at the numbers 883 five six
seven four seven and again we want to
encourage you ask for the book on the
Holy Spirit it's called the Holy Spirit
the need thank you Tony
we got Christopher listening in Canada
Christopher welcome to the program I
good afternoon father Ross and Doug Ross
and Mike Mike my question is I have
actually two questions first question is
after after the prohibition ends will
there be a time period where before
Jesus Christ returns or will he return
immediately and my second question is in
doing
Jesus Transfiguration in Chapter nine of
three mark chapter nine was yes Moses
and Elijah appeared to Jesus but as
we've studied before if a person dies
they mix they would rise up when Jesus
returned so how is it that Moses was
there how to meet Jesus on the mountain
over there okay thank you very much
Chris for two questions let's answer
them as quick as we can is there a time
period after the close of probation
before Christ comes yes the Bible tells
us that you then have the seven last
plagues when probation closes the people
of God have the seal of God or the mark
of the beast and once everyone has made
their decision then the seven last
plagues fall the plagues are not
designed to turn people to repentance it
is then too late and how long will that
be
well it seems to indicate in the Bible
it's less than a year because it says
all of her plates come in a day and in
prophecy a days a year
that means within a year so it could be
shorter than that it might be a matter
of months you think about how long the
world will last if the seas are all
blood in the fresh waters blood and and
men are being scorched with great heat
probably not very long second question
the reason you see of course Elijah went
to heaven in a fiery chariot the reason
that Moses appears on the Mount of
Transfiguration Moses was resurrected
now this is not in the Bible how long
Jewish tradition says three days after
Moses was buried God resurrected him we
believe it's true because Jude mentions
it in Jude verse nine said that Michael
would not dispute with the devil over
the body of Moses now why are they
disputing over the body except that
Michaels come to raise him and then
Moses of course appears so he God raised
him up so he could see the people cross
into the promised land that was his big
desire hope that helps a little
Christopher thank you very much and I do
have a book that talks about the
Transfiguration it's called the glorious
mount about the two witnesses we'll send
that to you and again the number to call
for that is 883 five six seven four
seven I asked of the book about called
the glorious mount about Moses and
Elijah appearing with Jesus and amount
of Transfiguration next qualies penny
listening from Washington State Penny
welcome to the program thank you very
much how are you guys doing good how can
we help you tonight penny this is it um
how does a person know if they're really
saved I've been struggling with that for
a really long time and partly because my
temple it looks like it should be
condemned
I have abused my body for my whole life
and I keep doing it and now I'm at a
point where I've got to go have chemo
because my blood Sugar's are so high so
all this time I keep thinking what do I
have to do how do I know if I'm saved or
not I keep not listening to what God's
telling me to do I
nor it I drink the milkshake and then I
asked for forgiveness and I I think
there's something wrong with that all
right that you're asking a good question
and it would not just be with your
struggle which sounds like it's with the
the food issue there's three areas where
Jesus was tempted you've got the lusts
of the flesh
you got the lust of the eyes and the
pride of life and he overcame in all
three of those areas to give us power
and an example that we can overcome and
even though you feel discouraged that
you've failed so many times don't ever
doubt God's love for you but he wants to
save you from your sin as you've
mentioned you know sin hurts us and
addictions slowly destroy us salvation
is always a prayer away the thief dying
on the cross turned to Jesus and so you
can turn to Jesus for forgiveness and
ask for strength
you know I empathize because I struggled
for years you know I was addicted to
cigarettes that would again be a lust of
the flesh it was a physical addiction
and oh you know what I ought to be tell
well anyway god help me quit smoking
what I ought to be telling you is I've
got a sermon online called cold
confession and maybe that's what Pastor
Ross was laughing I don't know if you
remember that yes I was addicted to ice
cream for 50 years no that means serious
uh-uh you got to listen to the sermon
and I tell about getting the victory
over a very serious addiction that was
causing health problems and people kind
of laughed they said how can you be a
dick the ice cream listen to the sermon
go to YouTube just type in Doug
Batchelor cold confession you can watch
it right now and I think it will
encourage you penny God wants you to
have the victory you want to you need to
for your health and I think you want to
also for your peace of mind Jesus love
for you is not affected by our failures
nothing can separate you from his love
but sin is deadly both physically and
spiritually and he wants you to have the
victory so please take a look at that
and I want to give you a book that's
Ross is probably thinking in the same
way
absolutely I think it's a practical book
and it'll be very helpful painting take
it take time to order it just call an
ass it's called tips for resisting
temptation and you know that all of us
face temptation in one way or another in
our lives and yeah it's a it's a
day-by-day battle but God does promise
to give victory and we've got some
practical tips on what a person can do
to gain the victory the number to call
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven and again make sure you
answer that book a penny it's called
tips for resisting temptation it's not
just for you for anyone wanting to live
a victorious Christian life what can we
practically do again it's called tips
for resisting temptation the number is
883 five six seven four seven next one
that we have is a wreck listening from
Bakersfield Rick welcome to the program
hi passers evening Oh my question is on
how to keep the Sabbath as a no work
life I know you know you can't you can't
work on the Sabbath so right now I'm
gonna predicament where I'm at you know
I'm in a job where I'm working on the
Sabbath and I just I want to do you know
I want to do the right thing
obey the Sabbath and well exceeding me
to law enforcement and I know I know
that you know that the ones are in the
medical field even if they work in the
Sabbath it's okay because they're doing
you know they're doing service you know
they're doing housework but is it the
same as law enforcement since you're
protecting even though you're in law
enforcement and you might work if
Saturday will you be doing the wrong
thing alright hey thank you Rick sure
appreciate your question in your
situation and we deeply appreciate
everybody that is working both in law
enforcement and especially these these
are difficult times for those in the
medical field as well and the people on
the front lines dealing with emergency
situations you know a law enforcement
would probably be a little different but
you know we tell everybody everybody
that believes in the commandments of God
you got to be careful if you're in one
of these emergency fields like nursing
or being a doctor you know if someone
has a physical need Jesus always healed
on the Sabbath
and but you wouldn't want to schedule
where you're working in a hospital every
Sabbath so you miss your fellowship you
miss your own spiritual nourishment you
would want to rotate your schedule if
you're in law enforcement I would try to
schedule with your your department and
friends so that they can maybe have
their day off and you get God's day off
and if there's an emergency there's an
emergency and you and you need to go
help but it's not healthy for a
Christian even in these emergency
situations to deliberately schedule
where they keep missing their their
fellowship and their worship because
that erodes your faith you know there's
an old saying that seven days without
Church makes one week it's a pun so yeah
we know we've got a book we finished
that you'll enjoy on how to keep the
Sabbath we'll send you a free copy Rick
the number to call is 800 eight three
five six seven four seven and again it's
just got a simple title it's called how
to keep the Sabbath we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
we got Paul listening in Arkansas Paul
welcome to the program thank you fasters
first time calling in I've heard your
ministry several times I'm a trucker so
I listen to Sirius satellite one one
forty one 1/4 inch easily anyway my
question is I've been attending this
church in Springdale Arkansas and they
believe in the Trinity the cross the
burial resurrection the whole nine yards
and I've never heard once then preach
about whether you can lose or save your
salvation or their interpretation of
scriptures of concerning the Millennium
now when I started there I was
befriended by one of the elders and we
had a lot in common
and about a month ago we were just
talking and I found out that I believe
once they've always say he believes you
can lose your salvation I'm pre
Millenium he's called millennium anyway
so he went to Hebrews chapter 6 verses
or through 6 trying to explain to me why
you can easily lose your salvation and
I've heard from other QA ministries
Collins
that uh the author of he was who was a
Jews speaking to the Jews who actually
believed in God but not Jesus Christ not
just wondering why does everyone who
believes you lose your salvation always
go to Hebrews 6 verse 4 through 6
alright great question Paul appreciate
that and I hope we can be friends there
are a lot of Christians out there on
both sides of this issue you've got some
Christians that live in fear from day to
day of their salvation they have no
peace then you have people on the other
extreme who say once you're saved you
can't be lost and they live sort of a
reckless life and they figure well it
doesn't matter how much I sin
I'm saved then you have Christians I
think that are in the category of they
believe that salvation is something that
you receive and you can have assurance
but you can lose it if you neglect your
relationship with the Lord so I'm in
that category and I think pastor Ross is
in that category I do believe that you
know John says that we might know that
we have everlasting life
Christ says that he has begun a good
work in you will perform it he is the
author and the finisher of our salvation
jesus said all that come to me I will
not lose or let go
none that the father gives me that does
not Trump or overrule the verses where
Paul said you know I can preach to
others and I myself can be a castaway
and the Bible says you are to work out
your own salvation with fear and
trembling and jesus said there'll be
some who say lord lord and you'll say
depart from me and you've got examples
in the Bible of people like Saul who was
called by the Lord spirit-filled but he
grieved away the Holy Spirit and he fell
on his sword and you've got to Balaam
who was a prophet of God but he became
greedy and he lost his salvation he
ended up being that killed in a battle
trying to curse God's people so you know
I doubt you'll see him in the kingdom so
there are several verses people use on
both sides of this issue if you're gonna
make a mistake you're probably better
off making the mistake of not being
presumptuous and thinking once I'm saved
I can do anything and I won't be lost
and the way some of my friends they
believe once saved always save the way
they deal with it they say well
if they if they did do turn away and
lose her salvation they never really
were saved well if you take that
argument then you're back where you
started where nobody really knows and so
I think it's better off to say what our
jesus said you'll know them by their
fruits do you have the fruits of the
spirit are you walking with the Lord now
we have a book I'd like to send you you
may be driving Paul but try and make a
mental note it's called can a saved man
be lost you will find it's scriptural
you'll find it comforting and it uses a
lot more than Hebrews chapter 6 verse 4
again if you'd like to receive that the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called can a saved man choose to be lost
and if you're unable to call or you
can't mail the book to your home you can
read it at the amazing facts website
right now just take a look at amazing
facts calm org and on our free library
you can actually type in that resource
can I save man choose to be lost and I
think it'll be a blessing thank you Paul
for your call we've got Marie listening
in New York Marie welcome to the program
oh yes thanks for taking my call I have
a question on spiritual abuse what
exactly is spiritual abuse if you could
give examples of that regarding pastors
and churches and my second question is
why is nobody in the church standing up
when our constitutional rights are being
taken away from us with this lockdown
and they were putting a spirit of fear
on the country and this 40 million
people out of work so all right good
Christmas anything like Thank You Marie
let me I see another question similar to
yours it's following but first spiritual
abuse in Christ time he talked about
religious leaders that would rob widows
houses and for a pretense they'd make
long prayers so people in ministry that
exploit ministry they use ministry to
take advantage of an exploit poor people
and people in need and that is spiritual
they're playing the religion card and
they're using it for selfish gain or
they're using it to have power over
people and to manipulate people and God
is going to judge those who do that on
your other question about how come more
people aren't speaking out about our
constitutional rights that are being
infringed upon with this shutdown well I
think some are speaking out there was
actually a Supreme Court ruling this
last Friday and I wasn't happy about it
but the United Pentecostal church I
think in Southern California finally
took it to the Supreme Court that the
governor of California they said did not
have the right to forbid them to
peacefully gather according to the
Constitution that the government should
not make laws that prevent the free
exercise of religion and the court ruled
it was a split decision that governor
Newsom here in California did have the
right to restrict gathering at least
during the the health issues now I think
that you know everyone needs to use
common sense and if there's something
contagious whether you're a church or
whether you're at a football stadium you
don't want to cause a pandemic and and
spread it and risk other people I wish
the government would educate people and
then trust people to use their judgment
instead of enforcing it it really
concerns me when the Supreme Court rules
on the government's right to restrict
the number of people that can gather it
may be a Just Cause now but the next
time that right is used it could be
pushed to an extreme so I was I was
unhappy about that and yes there are I
think some memory there are people who
are speaking up against that and I don't
know if we have time for another
question I think Matthew had a question
on the same thing see if we can quickly
get Matthew on Matthew got just a minute
or two but your question Matthew from
Canada answered I want to know what
implications does this have and
religious freedom in the 5 to 4 vote yes
thank you let me try and answer quickly
Matthew
Marie was asking about this yeah if you
haven't seen friends and this came in it
was I guess a late late ruling that a
split decision the court was pretty much
split down the middle Judge Roberts
wrote the decision and then of course
there was a dissenting decision that and
it was a suit brought by a Pentecostal
church against the governor of
California that is saying he can limit
how many people meet under certain
conditions and we think that's kind of
arbitrary and as I said it might be
reasonable now to ask churches that but
when the Supreme Court then backs the
government's right to restrict the
number of people that can peacefully
gather for worship the next government
leader could abuse that and then they
can point to this ruling and so we're
concerned that you know whenever there's
any if you're gonna err err on the side
of religious freedom it's been fought
for so hard this country was founded on
the right to peacefully gather in
worship so why a lot of the Puritans and
people came not all but many and I just
hate to see that infringed on or eroded
in any way listening friends we see so
many of you we didn't get to your
questions tonight we see Robert and
Beckham and Samuel and Loxley and others
give us a chance next week we trust that
you've been blessed by the program
especially we well we've seen our
audience just explode during this
lockdown and we're thankful that we're
able to do more Bible questions someday
this will alleviate we hope you stay our
friends and continue to tune in to learn
more about amazing facts go to our
website amazing facts dot o-r-g we offer
so much there and if you blessed keep us
on the air
just click and donate thank
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California terror attacks
natural disasters political instability
and global economic meltdown these are
the images people generally associate
with the tribulation and the day of the
Lord but did you know the Bible speaks
about another day of the Lord just
before the great Judgment Day amazingly
imprinted on the very fabric of time
itself is a 24-hour period called the
Sabbath that was meant to forever be a
time of restoration for every human
being a day the entire world is largely
forgotten you'll be surprised to learn
how this special day of the Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called
the last day of prophecy to order call
800 538 7 to 75 or visit a book store
calm written by the hand of God and
spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit af bookstore comm D Chino amazing
backs has a free Bible school that you
can do from the comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF as a RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]